So there are many ways you could improve this form. One of
the ideas you might have had as to improve the visual design
of the theme of the form, to make it look a little
bit more Android-y. Another thing we could of done is maybe making
the fonts a bit bigger, making the spacing a little bit wider,
just to make the form kind of flow better. Another idea would be
to validate the form, so the user knows what to type in
if they got something wrong. Nazmul, do you have any thoughts on this?
>> Yeah actually, if I were to answer this
questions like six, seven, or even eight years ago when I
had my start up, I actually would completely agree with everything
you said. I probably, like you, created this really awesome sign
in form. But the correct answer is actually not to have
one. The most important thing to do in this situation is
to remove this form in it's entirety. And replace it with
Sign In with Google or Sign In with Facebook or Sign
In with LinkedIn, who, or whoever your favorite social identity provider is.
There's no reason to subject your user to having to
fill out all these long forms when all they want to do
is use your application. That's like the worst time to
actually bring this up. Instead by removing this entire flow and
having a single button that they can use to sign
in, it makes their life easy. And it also makes your
life easy, because you can now get out of the username
and password business. And use social identity providers who provide the
service for free, reducing the amount of work you have to do and
also what your user has to do in order to use your application